[Música]
a veces evolución no es ver las cosas de
manera diferente a veces revoluciones
reflexionar sobre cosas que nos hemos
saltado y lo digo esto porque desde el
mundo textil desde el mundo de la moda
hemos pasado de unos momentos en los que
había una producción un sector que
generaba casi 500 mil empleos en españa
a un momento que tenemos 150 mil empleos
y eso es en parte por esa evolución que
hubo en el sector donde se buscó cómo
ser más competitivo o cómo dar mejores
precios y la única manera que había era
abaratando costes de producción
deslocalizando externalizando lo cual
supuso desempleo en nuestro entorno en
españa en europa en los países
desarrollados al hacer también que es
otra las reflexiones que tenemos que
hacer cada vez que apostamos más no sólo
en el sector de la moda sino en otros
sectores vamos pensando en que el low
cost los precios más baratos todo se
puede abaratar todo es posible tenemos
que reflexionar también que si los
precios low cost dan lugar a salarios
locos porque evidentemente si algo se
paga es porque alguien lo hace y si sean
personas que lo hacen tienen un salario
ese canal es salario se tiene que
repercutir
naturalmente en el producto llegamos a
esta situación en la cual se deslocaliza
todo se externaliza y tenemos precios
mucho más económicos consecuencia de
esas situaciones que si tengo que menos
margen y produzco más barato hago la
producción mucho más económica tengo que
apostar por volumen y para apostar por
volumen doy precio económico pero tienes
que tener mucha rotación en tus
productos que consumes textiles
camisetas vestidos y demás eso qué es lo
que hace ha generado la problemática de
la famosa economía circular que se está
hablando en estos momentos es decir se
consumen muchísimos más recursos del
planeta porque hay que hacer muchas más
prendas porque tienen menos durabilidad
las prendas por lo tanto estamos
castigando mucho más el planeta como
ocurría en el ejemplo que decía el
presentador sobre el papel además de eso
genera otro problema y el problema que
genera es que hay que transportar
muchísimas más unidades de prendas eso
genera contaminación bien por barco o
bien por avión
y el sector textil de la moda es el
segundo generador de residuos en el
planeta porque porque estamos volvemos a
lo mismo si tenemos que buscar volumen
eso lo que hace es que genere muchos más
desperdicios que cuando teníamos una
época en la que comprábamos prendas de
calidad que tenían una durabilidad y al
tener una durabilidad el consumo no era
menor el precio nada pero no un consumo
menor en cuanto a unidades monetarias sí
en cuanto a unidades de prendas entonces
la reflexión que tenemos es que muchas
veces vamos más deprisa de lo que nos
corresponde la evolución es necesaria
pero la evolución a veces es hacer cosas
que hacíamos antes de otra manera y nos
hemos saltado una serie de pasos la
tendencia
creo que es buscar para toda esta
evolución y la economía circular en un
sector competitivo como es el de la moda
es buscar el equilibrio como empresarios
yo desde el sector textil o cualquier
otro empresario la primera
irresponsabilidad que tenemos es verdad
que invertimos arriesgamos y eso lo
hacemos porque queremos que nuestro
dinero nuestra inversión nuestra apuesta
genere unos dividendos genere unos
recursos de la apuesta y de la inversión
que hemos hecho pero esa apuesta que
estamos haciendo a la vez tenemos una
gran responsabilidad como empresarios la
figura que en españa no está lo bien
vista que debería estar con él a
diferencia de otros países y es que
somos generadores de empleo y de riqueza
y esa generación de empleo y de riqueza
tiene que combinarse con la
competitividad y además tenemos que
hacerlo más sostenible es posible por lo
tanto yo creo que el avance es necesario
combinado con las tradiciones recuerdo
hace muchos años cuando visité japón
hace 20 veintitantos años nuestro
concepto de japón era un país súper
adelantado súper evolucionado lo es pero
nunca olvidaba sus tradiciones nunca
olvidaba que para llegar aquí no te es
olvidar de dónde partes y estas raíces
te dan la sostenibilidad para llegar al
otro lado lo que no puedes hacer es ir
dando saltos ni pasar de juanito a juana
por lo tanto creo que el equilibrio que
debemos buscar en nuestras empresas es
que parte de la producción
realice dentro de nuestras fronteras lo
que se denomina producción de proximidad
generando empleo y riqueza y parte de
ella tiene que hacerse en países de mano
de obra más económica más barata para
buscar la competitividad y buscar el
equilibrio conseguir el equilibrio entre
lo que es nuestra responsabilidad a la
hora de crear riqueza y empleo y lo que
es mantener la competitividad en este
sector como os decía la economía
circular es algo en lo que como somos
responsables en este segundo segundo
contaminador a la hora de los residuos
textiles pero es importante que seamos
conscientes que nuestra apuesta por la
calidad de los productos por esa
durabilidad es lo que puede hacer que
nosotros sigamos consumiendo moda
sigamos aportando riqueza como
empresarios y a la vez
contribuyamos a esa sostenibilidad
también dentro de todo este mundo
aparece la famosa digitalización la 4.0
la impresión en papel que se decía
anteriormente que lo que hace es reducir
los procesos consumir también menos
recursos de papel y apostar sobre todo
también por materiales naturales
materiales naturales que lo que hacen
evidentemente es que se van regenerando
tienen mucha menos cuantía muy
contaminación y los residuos que generan
como son biológicos pues se
autodestruyen por lo tanto no es como el
plástico que proviene del petróleo la
extracción y la generación de recursos
que
qué hace es mucho más contaminante están
surgiendo también empresas en el sector
de la moda economía circular que lo que
hace es aprovechar esos desperdicios
tóxicos del plástico y con ello las
redes de los pescadores los tapones de
las botellas y demás generando prendas
haciendo prendas que lo que hace es
darle una segunda vida reciclarlo y por
lo tanto contribuir a la sostenibilidad
del planeta que la moda española es un
sector importante que repito en nuestro
sector y en todos los sectores creo que
hay que apostar más por la calidad que
por la cantidad que es uno de los
sistemas a la hora de aplicar en nuestra
racionalidad en nuestro consumo el
sentido común y no ser hipócritas no ser
hipócritas porque todo esto que acabo de
decirle todo el mundo está de acuerdo
están encantados
y dicen es verdad que consumer calidad
hay que consumir durabilidad
tenemos que evitar contaminar los
procesos de producción en tercero país
en terceros países que tengan la
responsabilidad social corporativa a la
hora de quien lo está haciendo me
refiero a mano de obra infantil me
refiero también a la hora de utilizar
los productos químicos autorizados no
autorizados me refiero al consumo del
agua que se hace en la hora de la
producción de tejidos textiles
pero resulta que cuando vamos a comprar
nuestro corazón dice una cosa en nuestra
cabeza dice otra completamente diferente
y mientras ante pongamos el precio a
todo lo demás vamos mal hablamos mucho y
hacemos poco
y eso esperarnos un tiro del pie
eso esperarnos un tiro en el pie porque
estamos diciendo lo contrario que lo que
hacemos y mientras no lo hagamos podemos
tirarnos mucho tiempo hablando perdiendo
tiempo y tiempo pero realmente no
estamos haciendo lo que creemos que es
necesario y lo que tenemos que hacer y
me explico en muchas ocasiones vemos
cómo
no puedo ni debo decir marcas pero en
algún sitio
low cost low cost low cost este discurso
que acabo de decir lo compra
fundamentalmente la gente más joven
y son precisamente es lo que hacen cola
y dando vuelta a la manzana
entonces
menos hipocresía más consecuencia y hay
que veces que para evolucionar hay que
mirar el pasado y no olvidarnos nunca de
él porque es parte de nuestro futuro
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]